today's one minute monday is be
consistent i recently got a message on
youtube from one of my uh long time
viewers chefs thank you chefs wrote in
to say hey evan been out for a while
great to see that you're still doing
this every day i'm posting videos to my
youtube channel every single day new
videos go up you have to be consistent
this is the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs okay you start something
then you stop you start you stop you
start you stop you never gain any
momentum you need to do something every
single day to grow your business
consistency is so important and and i
know you may have you know you may only
be a part-time entrepreneur okay you may
have a job you have other
responsibilities i'm not saying jump in
and do it time every day but every
single day if it's half an hour a day
you're taking one action you have to be
consistent because that's how you're
gonna grow your business believe for
those who watch like the video thumbs up
below leave a comment click on my face
subscribe to the channel i'll see you
soon